Welcome back!
I hope you have all installed GHC
and played a little bit by typing in
expressions.
What we're going to do now is move beyond
simple expressions
and see how we can load full Haskell
programs
into GHC.
In Haskell, programs are not called
programs. Typically Haskell people refer
to their code
as scripts because
Haskell programs are maybe shorter
than normal code.
I just call them Haskell programs,
but the haskell parlance
is scripts.
New functions, if you want to
define a complete Haskell program,
you define them in a
text file that contains a list of function
definitions
and this text file
has a suffix .hs that indicates
that it's a
Haskell file.
Just like an HTML file has an
.html suffix, or CSS files have .css
suffix, or Java file
has a .java suffix,
a Haskell file is called whatever
.hs. So this is not mandatory,
but it's useful that you can see when you
list the files in a directory that you
can see that this
is a Haskell script.
Now when you
are using GHC,
what you do is you edit your
script in one window, using whatever
editor of choice,
and then whenever you make a change, you
load your
script into GHC and
start
executing expressions.
So that's the kind of workflow
that we will be using for most of the
course. For simple things
that's what you. Of course, when you're
building commercial Haskell applications
this is not what you do.
You will compile them into standalone
executables,
but for the purposes of this course, this
is the workflow: we have
the editor window open, we have the GHCi
interpreter open
and then we will load the scripts.
In this case,
we will create a
text file test.hs and in there
we put two function definitions.
The first one:
double of x equals x + x
- does what it promises -
and then we can quadruple by
calling double of double of x.
So we save that file and then
we start
GHCi and invoking it with
test.hs and now both the Haskell
standard library
and the functions quadruple and
double that we defined
in the test.hs will be
available. For example, we can call
quadruple of 10
and it will return 40, but we can also
still call all the standard library
functions. For example
we can take
double of 2 of this list. Double of 2 is
4, so this is the same as take 4,
so we take the first 4 elements
of the list.
Now what we do
is we just leave GHC open, we
return to our editor and
add
2 new definitions: one is factorial
and the other one is average.
Since we're starting here,
we are using some syntax that
we haven't introduced yet so
bear with me.
So product
of 1 to n - this thing here
is the list of values 1 up to n -
and then product is the
standard library function
that multiplies all the values
in a list, so
this is a good definition of factorial.
Then when we want to calculate the
average
of a list we sum
all the elements - the values of the elements -
and we divide that
by the length of the list.
Of course, this is not a very smart
implementation of average, but that
doesn't matter... we're not
here to define average, we're doing
this to learn
GHCi. The thing that we're using here is
this trick here in Haskell
is that when you put a function name
between these single back quotes,
it becomes an infix operator.
So if you write
x `f` y
that's really just syntactic sugar for
f x y. Some people like this thing
as an infix operator,
others like it just as a regular
operator
- it's your choice.
This is syntactic convention. So this is not
a string or anything,
it's really taking a function and turning
that into an infix operator.
Then in GHCi, we call reload
and it will read the file
test.hs, add all the new bindings that we just
defined
- that was for factorial, so we can now
call factorial
and then we can call average as well.
Here you see the workflow:
you have your GHCi open, your editor
you edit, you call reload, and then you
can try
your code out.
A few syntactic
things, or oddities in Haskell:
functions
and parameter names must begin with
lower case
letters.
If you define a function, it must be
of any of these forms.
But any of these
starts with a lower case
letter. You can use a regular quotes
if you're too lazy to
invent a name. That's
something that I often miss in other
languages, where I just want to say
x prime or
x double prime, et cetera.
If you define a type, a type
has to start with an
uppercase name and that's the
reason. In Haskell,
the types and identifiers
are in different namespaces and that's
determined
by whether it starts with a lower case or
upper case identifier. That can be
confusing if you come from a different
language like
Java, or C# or JavaScript.
The other thing is that in
Haskell we use
a very mild form of Hungarian
notation.
If a parameter has an
s suffix, so for example if you have a
parameter named
xs or ns or nss,
that means a list of values
of type x and this is a list of
values
of type n - sometimes the n doesn't
correspond to the
type name - but typically when you see an
s at the end you know that it's a list.
If there's 2 s's at the end
- like here -
you know that it's a list of lists.
Thats by convention. So if you want to
look like a real Haskell programmer,
you should always use this convention.
When your parameter is a list,
it always ends with s, and usually
Haskell identifiers are short
so you don't it elements,
you call it xs.
Another
interesting thing that Haskell has in
common with by Python
is that white space is significant.
The
exact rules are quite subtle, but
we are just using Haskell
in very simple ways, so this
is kind of sufficient. If you have a
sequence of definitions - like here -
they all have to start in the same
column. Here
a, b and c all start
in the same column.
In this case here,
b has a space to the left of it,
so now all these definitions don't start
in the same column.
That's wrong!
Or in this case, c
and a don't start in the same column as b..
also wrong.
White space is significant in Haskell,
so make sure that all your definitions
are lined up - this is called the layout rule.
The layout rule
is there to avoid writing
unnecessary syntax.
Haskell folks
like to write this:
a = b + c where
and then in the where clause we have
a list of definitions that
all start in the same column and then d
here stars in the same column as a,
so that belongs to the same group
as a.
You can write this with explicit
curly braces and semicolons
- if you want to -
but that looks a lot more
verbose.
Haskell programmers like brevity,
so they'll often use significant white
space.
This looks a little bit clowny.
In the Haskell world, when you write code like
this people will look like
"you didn't do enough wax on, wax off".
Here's some GHC commands that are
useful
and I really
invite you to play around with it
When you do the exercises for
subsequent lectures, make sure that you
leverage
GHC or whatever other compiler you use,
to help you. We have seen
reload, but you can also just
load a fresh script.
From the interpreter
you can open the editor, so you can edit
a file with a certain name,
or edit the current script.
This one here is super useful:
it gives the type of an expression and I do
this
all the time - I never write types myself.
I ask what the type is and I go
in the editor and paste in the type.
You definitely should use :?
and that gives you a list of all the
commands
with a small explanation.
Of course,
I hope that you will not use this
last command to quit GHC,
but that you will, for the next
eight weeks,
be constantly using GHC.
There will be a lot of exercises
and the exercises will be on the website.
All these exercises,
you should be able to
do them in any language. You don't
have to use
GHC, but in this case, since this lecture
is about
GHC, they will be
GHC-specific.
In general,
as I said in the very first lecture, this
is a course
about functional programming. It's not a
course about Haskell and it's definitely
not a course about GHC,
but in this specific case the exercises for
this chapter and
for this lecture are on GHCi.
Happy hacking and
see you all next week!